[Music]
yo what's up it is monday morning april
11th what is happening thickies stickers
thicker tears that gums
hope everybody
is doing
fantastic
your boy looks a little sunburnt i get
that i did do the tough mudder uh this
past saturday
in uh glen helen raceway which is in san
bernardino california about an hour and
45 minutes from where we're at right now
in calabasas
uh i just didn't even think about
sunscreen it was 94 degrees out
and your boy got some sun on the face
and i have some weird tan lines going on
but your boy did complete the 15k it's
just over i think it's around nine and a
half miles i think a little under nine
half miles
um i want to say thanks everybody that
came out the first time i did the thick
mudder which in lake elsinore which is
kind of right outside
temecula kind of area they kept saying
la which was insane i didn't realize it
to fans like hey dude that's nowhere
near la fairpoint um
we had around 400 sign up for that one
for this one we broke 500. so the
movement is happening joined the thick
mudder movement the tough mudder
movement it is just a grand old time i'm
telling you man and we offered a 5k and
15k this time
and uh
it's just such a fun experience man and
uh mitrione decided to run with this
and
it was matt's idea first of all so matt
goes so we flew matt in from
indianapolis to do the fight companion
and he got here on friday
and then he goes uh
on friday afternoon he goes dude you
have a tough mudder tomorrow i want in i
went
oh okay uh have you been running you
just no not at all i went yeah you
should be fine it's more about the
experience
it's gonna be a good time come on out
she's like cool i go i'll pick you up
pick him up and uh he goes wait hold up
it's 15k oh yeah dude he goes how far is
that it's like nine miles goes oh [ __ ]
it's gonna be a beast more of a mental
grind than anything your body will hold
up
you know matt threw all the years of
football and fighting as arthritis and
so he's every bit of 280 pounds too not
fat just you know 280 pounds would he
pass the usada test no of course not but
who cares so he
um he goes out there and uh he's fine at
first and then uh his knees just
couldn't take it his his his body just
starts kind of breaking down on him
started breaking down on him and i think
he lasts for about three miles and do it
your last for about three miles but it
was a great time man we had a great crew
run with us the way it goes is
so my crew my heat was at 10 45 but for
the thick mudder it's there's like three
or four different heats so not everybody
gets to run with me but we all see each
other at the end so there's like a 10
o'clock 10 30 10 45 11 i was in the 10
45 group so everybody runs but the way
you'll start out and there's like 40 of
you and you're all talking and as the
thing gets going
you'll see there's about five of you you
you have a group of five you ran at
casey i mean you ditched everybody and
finished first whatever but hopefully
you want to run the next one but i'm
telling you it's such a fun freaking
time man hopefully more uh people around
thick boys studios does it big george
you should be doing the next one
you should be doing i don't know why
meatball missed it um big mike why not
uh
george coming in from chicago i'd like
to get george out there at least for a
5k
and my dad wants to do the 5k with uh
big j so we'll figure it out man but
it's telling me man there's there's
nothing but it's such a fun experience
it's such a fun freaking experience man
so shout to all the thickies who came
out for the thick mudder next one we're
trying to figure out now your boy it
won't be in la your boys probably headed
to chicago in august
i am in philly on tour when there's a
thick mudder
so it's like could i do a thick mudder
and then do two shows at night um i mean
i did do a thick mountain do a companion
which that was a bit of a beast but it's
a grand old time so we'll figure it out
man but uh shout out to everybody who
got out of their comfort zone and did
the thick mutter and and finished it and
you realize that you know yeah it's a
bit of a grueling thing but it's also
just such a bonding fun experience man
so i'll see everybody at the next one
man it was just such a
fun time yeah papa shop was in town
my dad
he's uh he's a little old school so um
he wants my kids to to kind of
i don't know have the same
experience he had you know my dad's 60
something
so he brought uh checkers he brought
checkers for my six-year-old
the tough thing about that is checkers
was i think created in like 1904 so when
you bring it to my son he's used to
playing roadblocks or these other games
he's like what the [ __ ] is this you know
it's tough hurts my dad's feelings i
think i'm like dad
you know he's [ __ ] still on 22 man
these kids they're just not into
trackers so it hurts his feelings but
papa shop left town today but
sorry dad checkers you know 222. i'm
with you i like a good game of trekkers
but these kids aren't into it man
um but we did have a cowbest fight
companion on saturday night i think the
longest one we've ever had
because there were so many uh decisions
on the main card so we go as long as the
pay-per-view goes there was what four
decisions out of the five fights
the only uh non-decision was the main of
the main event with volkanovsky korean
zombie which can you owe me a bottle of
buffalo trays something like that yeah
yeah what do you mean something like
that or jameson maybe no no you like
buffalo
yeah yeah all right yeah but buffalo
chase is cheaper i think it is cheaper
yeah yeah yeah buffalo trace yeah coco
on that route buffalo trace sorry you're
not getting the then
then
[Music]
i'm gonna kick this thing off and if you
haven't seen the cowbest fight companion
with matt matrio and josh thompson and
brian count it is a fun one so go watch
it right now it's available right now on
thick boy
and also during the fight command we uh
showcase the poster for the special that
drops april 28th on thick boy youtube i
can't wait for you guys to see this your
boy has been grinding
grinding to knock this thing out the
whole team that thick boy has been
grinding so i'm freaking stoked man so
you guys will see that um
just excited man we we posted the uh the
artwork for you guys i guess it's just
uh it's a picture that my boy troy
conrad's um
took and then the title the gringo poppy
it is 30 minutes of lighting my latin
family up so
um i think you guys are gonna dig it man
i think you're gonna dig it um speaking
of i'm on tour this thursday friday
saturday tickets are damn near sold out
for a freaking stand up live in phoenix
arizona i don't think your boys ever
sold out stand up live uh it's a big ass
venue so i'm excited man i think all the
vips are sold out and there's few
tickets left for general admission so
get them while they're hot
and that is this thursday friday
saturday in phoenix arizona looking
forward to that eating a lot of jt's
wings hanging out with the boys i got
chappelle lacy david lucas the squad is
out there in full effect that's this
thursday friday saturday in phoenix
arizona but let's get into the freaking
usc 273 card um i'm just going to kick
this off with what i thought was the
main event and basically what
everybody's talking about with hamzap
versus gilbert burns
um
you know i always like to give mvps of
the fight card
there would be two mvps here it would be
al jermain sterling which i'll get into
after this al jamaine sterling for just
what he's had to deal with and
you know the hate that he's had and all
that stuff and then dealing with the
pressure and performing like you did but
then also the other mvp would be gilbert
burns you should talk about gilbert
burns remember the reason one of the
reasons hamzad went from 11 to 2 is
10 through 3 ain't signed up to fight
hamza he's this
chechen monster loch ness monster
bigfoot whatever you want to call him
this mythical creature that nobody
wanted to fight and gilbert bernswin
he's just another human being man he's
not some you know untouchable
fighter he's like i'm down to do it and
you know i would say myself included a
lot of these mma experts
um you know kind of
under-appreciated gilbert burns and i'll
be the first one to admit i owe him a
complete apology i thought he was gonna
get absolutely annihilated uh because i
am on the hamza train i'm on the hamza
train i'm completely on the hamza train
you know this
but the train's gonna make some stops
along the way i i was going pretty ham
last week if you listen i thought he
could be
welterweight champion middleweight
champion light heavyweight champion
let's pump the brakes a little bit
brenton let's chill out though you know
chill out because it is mma and you got
it dude this is what i love about mixed
martial arts at the highest level
is hamzap was this guy and you know i
was the one one of the the guys feeding
this to everybody you know hums out this
guy who's been untouchable you look at
his first four fights in ufc the this
compu strike numbers and it's like 95 to
1 and just
annihilating people [ __ ] annihilating
people and he looks untouchable but this
sport is has a great way of showing
um
kind of you you got to be humble man you
got to be humble because
for uh the number 11th guy which he
deserves to be right to be number 11 to
fight the number two guy
um you know it's a huge jump man and
gilbert burns is number two for a reason
and it wasn't that long ago he had
camaro who's been wobbled granted he
lost that fight but he did you know land
on camaro usa and gave him all he could
handle and uh camaro ended up doing his
thing that's why he's pound for pound uh
great right now but
you know y'all must have forgot
including me i blame ct i don't know
what you blame it on but y'all must have
forgot gilbert burns is a [ __ ]
savage dude he's so damn good
we all forgot that and i owe him an
apology and gilbert burns for him to go
in there and perform like he did he did
lose the fight 29-28 they got that right
um you know
my hat's off to gilbert man nobody
wanted to fight this guy nobody saw even
a small
[ __ ] in his armor and gilbert you know
that first round was tough and he got
dropped with that book called a jab but
you know he switched stance it was a
right hand um
you know so he got a little bit of
trouble it looked like hamzad was going
to do what hanzot does and gilbert
answered the bell and you know came back
and won some rounds there and i do wish
that was a five-round fight
i really do i wish i had a five-round
fight but
the the
got to be a little critical of homs out
here because i've been so
genu
generous super uh
kind of complimentary of him and
rightfully so he he's shown no chinks in
his armor
but for this fight i guess the the first
red flag for me now granted i'm two
uh tiger thick whiskey's deep when he
came out
and i missed some of i re-watched the
entire card yesterday
i i guess the one thing that kind of
bothered me if you're if you're on the
hamza train and listen i'm the one
putting the [ __ ] coil in the train
right now right nicole i'm [ __ ] here
trying to get this thing going
all right let's take a little break
before we get back to the program the
shop show because i guess i'm tell you
dudes two out of three men will
experience some form of hair loss by the
time they're 35 imagine being 35 in bald
imagine being 35 looking like george
costanza you don't want that more than
50 million bros in the u.s suffer from
male pattern baldness i see it i'm meet
and greet so i'm like dude you boys need
keeps yep keeps offers a simple
affordable stress-free way to keep your
freaking hair you meet with a doctor a
virtual doctor all right
come straight to your door we got 24 7
care and support if you got any
questions we've got you covered it's low
cost treatments start just 10 per month
10
10 to keep your freaking
long
lust
locks that's right man keeps has
everything you need delivered straight
to your door discreet little package
proven results nobody has to know you're
doing this for your hair remember
prevention is key here treatments can
take four to six months see results so
act fast when it comes to your hair save
more spend less with my friends at keeps
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss you don't have to look
like that anymore go to keeps.com shop
that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com shop if you don't have spell
keeps you don't deserve good here that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com shop to get your first
month free
keeps.com shop let's keep it rolling man
because the nba playoffs are here it's
next level basketball and get ready for
all the action by betting the play-in
tournament with draftkings sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
nba new customers can bet five dollars
on any team to win and get 150 dollars
in free bets instantly you clinch a win
no matter what all draftkings sportsbook
customers can also bet on nba hoops with
the same game parlays combine multiple
bets from the same game for a bigger
payout your boy always does parlays here
the more legs you add the more money you
can win plus for each day of the play-in
get a risk-free bet up to ten dollars if
your same game parlay
doesn't hit download the draftking
sportsbook app right now use promo code
shop at five dollars on any nba team to
win their game during the play-in
tournament and get 150 dollars in free
bets instantly that's promo code shobb
at draftking sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the nba
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
supply ch see show notes for details see
next page for directions for disclaimer
um
you know
hamzat's demeanor as gilbert burns was
walking into the octagon you know
sitting on the cage a little
loosey-goosey um
i'm all for showmanship and there's
stuff like that but even connor doesn't
do that stuff that that's you know i i
don't know where that
i think you have to have that
total self belief in which he does i
think that's where this is is coming
from a good place
but you're also fighting the number two
guy in the world and there's a time for
that
and you haven't earned that yet
and you haven't passed that milestone
yet so i think this was a case of a
y'all must have forgot gilbert burns is
freaking good mace the number two guy in
the world for a reason and also hamzat
overlooked them thought he was gonna
just completely molly whop him and learn
the hard way and didn't take this as
serious as he should
so that was alarming to me as a as a guy
as the president of the hamzat fan club
that's kind of alarming the other thing
is
i i would love to hear hamzaat's team's
what their game plan was
i didn't really see a game plan i saw
him fighting straight up fighting
i think he's such a savage that there
are no game plans i think he's going to
figure it out and
you know against the guys that he was
fighting
you can get away with that just based
off skill set you'll figure out when
you're in there any you know again you
look at the comp strike numbers you
completely mollywhopped everybody so
like yeah keep doing your thing
but when you get to these upper echelon
guys you know i'd say
really top 10 10 through 1 in the champ
there should be some sort of game plan
involved there and i just didn't
i'd be curious i'm sure they had one i
i'd be curious if hamza actually stuck
to it because hamzad
the much bigger fighter ranger fighter
longer fighter
none of that
was a factor in this fight he completely
kind of disengaged you know fighting
from a distance being the longer fighter
throwing kicks using his reach to get in
to to get takedowns he initially went
for the takedowns he got him down early
and then after that there wasn't much of
it and i think he was a little surprised
about how strong gilbert burns is in the
clinch but i would just be curious what
his game plan was because
you know he was just
sitting the pocket trading with the
smaller fighter and got caught and that
shot that gilbert prince hit him with i
think that drops 99.9 of the ufc and uh
hamzad you know showed he has a freaking
granite chin which is what we want but
i'm i'm just curious what the game plan
was
um because if that fight goes in the
fourth and fifth round again this coming
from the the president of the hamzad fan
club
if that was going fourth and fifth round
a little worried a little worried there
um
but on the
other side of that
i think it's good too
for hamza i think this is such a
learning experience because
let's say the ufc did what they did with
darren till right and they go all right
forget your number eleven forget gilbert
burns forget the you know leon edwards
or you know any list anybody you want in
there
you're going straight to kamar usman or
straight to kobe covington i don't think
he wins that fight on saturday night i
think he needed this learning experience
i think it was the best thing that
happened to him and i i think it's good
that it was three rounds because five
rounds could have got a little dicey
there and he's never been in those deep
waters
and
you know so i i think
hamzat from this past saturday to his
next fight is going to grow tremendously
because i think he's going to realize
like that was close that was a close
call we got hit with some shots we
probably didn't need to get hit with we
didn't really stick to a game plan we
kind of just shot from the hip we won
and obviously he lived up to the hype
because for the number 11 guy to beat
number two guys
nutzos so the hype is real so you we're
still all on the hamza train and i think
you should have some level of confidence
and if he's a stock you're not selling
your stock on hamzad you're probably
doubling down because i think for him to
learn
uh to be in there to go three rounds i
mean i'm talking tough rounds with
gilbert burns and he lost some of those
rounds one of those rounds for him to go
in there and face adversity and be able
to come back and you know deal with it
the way he did with a world-class guy in
gilbert burns
if again if he's a stock you're you're
you're glad it happened here and not
when he fights camaro oozman and kobe
covington
because kobe covington and kumar
richmond are different animals than
gilbert burns and they have a different
set of skills that
he would have learned and it would have
been a loss so i think it's a blessing
in disguise that this went three rounds
went to decision he faced adversity and
i i i would bet my bottom dollar when he
if he fights kobe covington on abc which
dana said is probably next with him
which we'll get to that
i guarantee you he's not sitting on the
cage you know like it you know he's
hanging out at happy hour
those days are done those days are done
i didn't like that out of him i just
didn't and again i'm
i was a guy you know if you listen to
the shop show last week it was like oh i
don't get how gilbert's gonna deal with
this and get molly wopped and let's just
bring on the next guy and you know
gilbert burns number two for a freaking
reason man and uh i don't think hamzad
or gilbert burns uh lost any stock at
all if anything you know it's one of
those fights where gilbert stock went up
i feel sorry whoever has to fight
gilbert next i think you realize how
[ __ ] good gilbert burns is i think
for hamzat he learned so much that night
he learned so much that night his team
learned so much that night where it's
gonna pay off
so what's next for hamza well dana did
say kobe come to on abc
sign me up take my money but it's free
so don't take my money
yeah it's free so you don't have to pay
any money that's cool but it's on abc
right so
just going into this fight man
you know
you got to realize is kobe comington
does do the heel thing from the wwe and
love him or hate him he's very well
known for it and he's probably the best
in the game at doing it can be a little
cringy but it's his thing
he backs it up because he's a phenomenal
fighter he's the best welterweight in
the world not named kamal usman so he
knows going into this fight
you know
especially with what's going on
politically across these and the war
going on with russia and stuff like that
kobe i guarantee will make this about
usa versus russia even as chechnyan it's
close enough for him so the whole
narrative and it's gonna get ugly and
i'm all for it i'm all for it is kobe's
gonna put a freaking flag in the ground
and go this is russia versus america
whose side are you on and it's gonna
build up to that abc card and it's gonna
do gangbuster numbers
but i i will say this
and again this coming from the president
of the homs fan club if that same that
same version of hamza shows up that
thought gilbert burns if he doesn't
learn from the experience which i think
he does i'm just caveat this with if he
doesn't make some adjustments he will
not beat colby covington which is insane
to say because go back to remember last
monday and i went hamza is going to be
the welterweight champ the middleweight
champ who's going to be in that light
heavyweight
chill brendan chill dude
chill dude
um
we you you really got a bank on hamzat's
team going back watching that come up
with a game plan to beat colby comington
because now you're facing completely
different animal you're facing a colby
comington who
again if
outside kamar usman is the best
welterweight on the planet he's a he's a
little bigger than gilbert burns he is
you're not taking the chance him taking
him down is not good and also
this is five rounds that fourth and
fifth round is going to be a nightmare
and colby just gets better round after
round after round so if you're homs that
fan you got to hope that he gets it done
the first three rounds really the first
two
because colby he he comes like a goddamn
banshee and during the companion
you know
they're like man you just
you got to find someone that can
pressure hamza and get him on his back
foot
yeah kobe compton
he has the most insane pressure that
he's just non-fucking stop man
so what i love about this now
is camaro watch that fight colby watch
that fight
i would imagine knowing those guys
they're going i'll fight him oh yeah
yeah get y'all i'll take that i'll i'll
take that checking in down oh that's
what i'll do i can get rid of this guy
they're probably foaming at the mouth
man
you know but only camaro and uh colby
the rest of the vision is like yeesh but
kobe and uzman with their
with their set of skills are going i'll
do this hell yeah that was three rounds
yeah let's look we're you know we're
champions we fought in those deep waters
he this chechen can't swim in those deep
waters let's see what happens when
you're in the fourth and fifth round
and colby and usman will have a game
plan for that and hopefully hamzad's
team and his team's brilliant and he
comes from a great camp
you know you you can't fly by the sea of
your pants you can't you sit on top of
the octagon and think this is you know
happy hour and stuff like that those
boys are coming man those boys are
coming and
um if it's the same homs out that showed
up against gilbert burns he will not win
that fight guarantee it
so i again i i'm still on the hamsa
train i think we have some stops along
the way okay it's not direct train
travel here we're gonna have some uh
layovers um
and you gotta learn in those layovers
how to get it done so
again it's similar to i was such an
anthony joshua fan when he fought
klitschko um
you never know how much you can invest
in a guy because to be a great you
sometimes you have to get
hit with punches you didn't see you got
to get dropped and a fighter
it's easy to be a fighter when you're
dominating and just mopping through
everybody that's not the fight game the
fight game unfortunately comes with
losses or
failures whether it's you know you
should have zigg when should a zag and
get dropped and you come back or
somebody has your back or you get taken
down we've never been taken down
and as far again i keep referencing the
stocks i'm not even a big stock guy but
you guys get the analogy here for for
hamza you know to face adversity and
come back
you want that in a fighter man because i
guarantee you especially the next three
fights that he has it's not going to all
go his way and we if you're if you're
going to invest in a fighter you got to
know that that guy's not going to give
up that he has that
dog in him to to lose around and be able
to bounce back and forget about it and
fight through it fight through adversity
and again the biggest example is anthony
joshua when he fought klitschko and you
know before that he starching everybody
then goes in there gets dropped bounces
back up knocks him down klitschko who he
knows a [ __ ] legend pops back up
drops him again it's this back and forth
back and forth you look at the the andy
ruiz fight where he overlook this short
fat mexican gets completely annihilated
and then the rematch absolutely
trashes him you want we want this out of
fighters because if a guy's just
dominating non-stop
it's it's you know you never know what
they're going to do when they when they
face adversity so hamzat faced this
first adversity and it's if again if
you're a hamzat fan for his career this
was the best thing to happen now you
gotta pray and i honestly believe he's
gonna learn from this
and comes into the next fight a little
more respectful a little more serious
and a little more kind of focused on the
game plan because you're not just gonna
fight colby or fight camaro and edge out
a win you're not those guys are too high
level they're too high level and um
it's a tough task man so
hats off to hamzat major props to
gilbert burns definitely fight of the
year candidate
um and hamza lived up to the hype
beating the number two guy in the world
and you know i'm sure hamzad's gonna be
you know two or three now which is
fantastic so the the train continues and
i'm still on board i still think he's
the next big thing in the ufc
if he makes some adjustments if he comes
up with a game plan and if he learns
from this last fight
and he's a smart dude clearly he's
complete [ __ ] savage so
we'll we'll see what happens there but
um you know the jump again it's a big
jump even from gilbert to colby it's a
big jump and he's on the fast track and
he has the skill set and the demeanor to
get it done
he just has to humble himself and get
back into the training room and focus on
a game plan and just kind of go from
there but um it was it was a great fight
what's this gin i just saw this uh
from his coach he just posted something
about
the whole hype train thing let me see
let me see if this is it oh there it is
people ask me what i told hum humza at
the end of round two this is what i told
him stop brawling there you go
there you go i'm telling you he's a
great [ __ ] coach so this is uh andres
andre general
so this is him talking about the fight
people ask me why i told hamza end of
round two this is what i told him stop
brawling stop having a street fight use
your straight punches and keep it easy
this is an easy fight if you don't brawl
again not a game plan
all you have to do is keep him on your
jab and have patience correct don't make
it harder than it has to be correct
nothing else was needed just fast jab
and sometimes a straight right keeping
your distance because you're the bigger
fighter to not get hit with the hooks
correct a shorter fighter landing hooks
means you're so
close and you have no business being in
there
i told him to stop giving everyone a
show and just keep it boring and simple
it's the other thing when there's so
much hype behind a guy
you you feel pressure to keep it
entertaining
and sometimes again at the highest level
being entertaining isn't always the most
important thing you you got winnings the
most important thing and we forget this
a lot of people forget this it's still a
[ __ ] professional sport and if you
lose dude if you were to lose this bro
we we'd as as a
just as a business we're in the hamzap
business we'd much prefer you to stick
to a game plan make it boring and
outclass gilbert burns then go through a
war and eek your way out of it man
so this coach is spot [ __ ] on man i
told him stop giving everyone a show and
just keep it boring and simple to not
force anything just be fast and land on
his feet this was the game plan all
along there you go didn't stick to the
game plan easier than wrestling easier
than grappling in flash as we saw that
gilbert with all respect is a tough
gritty brave warrior all of respect to
him these guys gave a show to the public
but as a coach i don't care about the
public i care about the easiest way to
win with minimum damage that's my number
one job to protect the fighter everyone
talks about the hype training is over no
how many fighters in the beginning of
the career is not even against top
ranked component had uh absolute
lackluster performance in their career
you must spell career uh shall i rack
them up champions legends list goes on
this means nothing a famous basketball
player told me once it's hard winning
damn hard my opinion about this is that
hanzo was 40 last night because he went
in with the mindset they wanted to knock
him out and show everyone correct no
game plan who cares about everyone
people only support and love when you're
winning correct so the goal is to win
but like it were he wanted a war i was
very upset because i believe uh and know
what he can do you haven't even seen
that yet it's scary
learning listening
learning listening curve blessed to have
the world's best team grown all-stars
drink centers here's all of you
people are gonna under underestimate us
now big mistake be my guest
yeah i agree i i don't think they
underestimate you now i think that we
pulled back kind of the cover and if
you're colby and camaro you're going
we can beat this guy before absolutely
not there's no
no sign of any kind of [ __ ] in the arm
right now
i'm telling you come on colby are going
off 100 give me the contract before like
nah [ __ ] that man no way now mm-hmm
those guys are into it but it's again
and i you know i don't see anything
until jim brings us up this coach is
spot on there was i mean it's clear as
day any i don't say casual thing because
they don't know as far as game plan but
the hardcore is like yeah that was just
a straight brawl you're not going to
beat colby camaro brawling it's not
happening you're going to lose
minimum by decision if not get finished
later in the fourth and fifth you can't
fight at the top level and not have a
game plan it's not gonna happen and
that's why it's coach price so [ __ ]
upset remember those coach take time
away from their family and friends they
put so much energy in you and i'm sure
it was like eight week camp and he's
with darren till doing smash bros and
all this [ __ ] and there's a game plan
then you get in there and you work on
nothing that we've covered for eight
weeks you know infuriating that is it's
nuts so his coach probably like dude
what the [ __ ] are you doing man you're
gonna [ __ ] around and lose this thing
gilbert is no punk man
but
thank god he got it done and got the win
man so
hats off to hamza hats off to gilbert
burns let's move on
on the co-main event alderman sterling
peter yon it's the most controversial
one it was a split decision
watched it yesterday
here's here's the problem with this so
al jermaine you know going into that
first fight against uh yan
became championed by an illegal need to
down opponent right
not his fault things happen
his kind of hate came you know he tossed
the belt inside that gun and then
shortly after that hours after he's
posting the belt saying he's the real
champ all the stuff
what do you expect they gotta do man
what do you want to do but you gotta you
know do what do what you gotta do and
believe in your heart that you're champ
so he ran with that and he obviously got
a lot a lot of hate let's keep it
rolling man because the nba playoffs are
here it's next level basketball and get
ready for all the action by betting the
play-in tournament with draftkings
sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the nba new customers can bet
five dollars on any team to win and get
150 dollars in free bets instantly you
clinch a win no matter what all
draftkings sportsbook customers can also
bet on nba hoops with the same game
parlays combine multiple bets from the
same game for a bigger payout your boy
always does parlays here the more legs
you add the more money you can win plus
for each day of the play-in get a
risk-free bet up to ten dollars if your
same game parlay
doesn't hit
download the draftking sportsbook app
right now use promo code shop at five
dollars on any nba team to win their
game during the playing tournament and
get 150 dollars in free bets instantly
that's promo code shobb at draftking
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of the nba minimum age and
eligibility restriction supply see
sea show notes for details see next page
for directions for disclaimer
last app then we get back to the show
ufc 273 breakdown
you've got back-to-back meetings you got
errands to run you got chores to take
care of you got kids chomping at the bit
you got a to-do list you need some help
from my
buddies at doordash you can get dinner
household essentials everything on your
grocery list delivered that's right
what do you want for dinner tonight
maybe you want one of your favorites
maybe you're cooking at home you missed
out on a recipe you missed out on an
ingredient doordash got you covered man
all right this past year has taught us
to save your every moment together spend
less time prepping and cooking more time
with the people that you love with the
help of doordash get what you want to
eat right now right to your door with
doordash along with the restaurants you
love you can now get groceries and other
essential items like a toothbrush one
can of coke whatever it is delivered
with doordash get drinks snackaroos
other household items in under a
freaking hour craving late night ice
cream like your boy
often does here cool man maybe you
forgot that key ingredient for dinner or
maybe just need to stock up for the week
with doordash you get everything in the
app with over 300 000 partners you can
support your neighborhood go to's
or choose from your favorite national
restaurants like popeye's chipotle
cheesecake factory ordering is easy
order your items and they will be left
outside of your door if you want or you
can actually just hand it off to another
human for limit time the viewers and
listeners of the shop show can get 25
off and zero delivery fees are your
first order of 15 or more when you
download the doordash app enter the code
shop show that's 25 off up to 10 value
and zero delivery fees on your first
order when you download the doordash app
in the app store enter the code shop
show sch aub show don't forget that's
code shop show for 25 off your first
order with doordass subject to change
terms apply but i thought
beside you know that comes out gilbert
there's a lot of pressure on both those
guys but
i thought nobody had more pressure on
them than al jermain sterling and uh
josh thompson didn't agree during the uh
broadcast of the calves fight companion
because he was like no you know he he
not no pressure
but i completely disagree because for al
jermaine
you know he was getting his ass whipped
in that first fight with john it didn't
look like he was gonna go his way at all
he ends up losing so i'm sorry ends up
winning by default he's getting all this
hate so i thought there's so much
pressure to prove to all his naysayers
and all the haters which you don't have
to prove anything those people but for
him it was just
for the ufc fan base you know to come at
him like they did i just felt he had so
much to prove and i you know i thought
al jamaine in the first fight going into
it not once i started out like i was
completely wrong which happens often but
i thought al jamaine athletically he's
unorthodox i i thought his wrestling
pedigree and stuff like that would be
too much for peter young and uh the
first fight that was not the case
has surgery has neck surgery which is a
major surgery a lot of people come back
different from it he's going into this
huge rematch to prove that he could
actually be a champion
and you know peter yan has been active
active as [ __ ] right corey sanderhagen
while al james sit on the sidelines even
though he's the champ so there's a this
animosity is building up for al germain
so i just thought he had so much going
against him
and uh i was rooting for him i was
rooting for him like nobody else on the
card because i want him to win
and
again what happens here too and it sucks
for al-germain and i wish dana didn't do
this dana as soon as the
fight ends is in the press conference
well the judge got wrong on that one did
they
but did they so dana has so much power
and when he says that
the
the sheep
for lack of a better word the sheep go
dana said he didn't win he didn't win
it's like dude come up with your own
opinion man go back and watch that fight
and i wish dana would wait until he
watched the fight like we saw the fight
watch it a second or third time before
you jump to that conclusion because by
saying that
that gives everybody out there the
casuals the mma experts especially on
espn or if you work for ufc now all of
them go algerman yet you know he didn't
win that fight which isn't true it's
just not true nobody got cheated out of
anything that was a close [ __ ] fight
that's why it's a split decision in that
second or third round
i believe they should give
10 8 out more frequently
to dominate a guy that long be on his
back that long and control a guy for
that long
i'm not mad at 10 8 but they didn't give
a 10 8 that's fine so we know al jermain
won the second and third lost the fourth
fifth was closer
but we'll give fourth and fifth to jan
two and three no debate there's no
argument algerman completely dominate
completely dominated i would have liked
a 10-8 for maybe that second or third
round but all right we don't get that so
you gotta go the first round this whole
fight is predicated off one round
so for anybody including dana white or
any mma expert out there to go he didn't
win that fight
i'd love to hear the argument
i'd love to hear the argument because
you're because if you're based in that
first round you're saying because peter
yan was the aggressor he won the fight
because he was the aggressor won that
first round because octagon control
which is what that is when you're
marching forward when you're the
aggressor that's the last thing that the
judges should judge it based off of
you're judging based off damage and
strikes landed
so let's go to the numbers let's go the
numbers because remember
the last thing being judged is octagon
control
so
strikes landed right and who's doing the
most damage so let's go the first two
things that matter the most
perion landed i think two kicks in the
first round
sterling landed more shots through more
shots
i didn't come up with a criteria
i don't come up with the judging you
guys did
based off that criteria al germain won
that first round
that's not al germain come up with the
judging he didn't come up with a scoring
criteria
the commission did you guys did
that were
at the mercy of that judging criteria
based off that criteria this is very
black and white
al jermain sterling based off your
judging criteria won that first round
hands down
no argument
based off your criteria
that we all have to go off of
that i have nothing to do al-germain has
nothing to do with it based off the
criteria that you guys always go off of
al germain won that first round
very black and white close round 100
i'll give you that but based off those
important factors strikes landed
damage inflicted
last one you're going to go to is
octagon control and peter young won that
one we lost the first two so who would
you give the round to al germain so say
al germain won the first round
in what
[ __ ] world do you live in where you
wouldn't give him another two rounds in
the second and third
based off your criteria that i didn't
design that i i'm at the mercy like you
guys are and the fighters are based off
those criterias
so algerman won the first round
completely dominate the second round
completely dominate the third round
definitely lost the fourth round
fifth round was close but i'll give it
to yon
that's three out of five
that would make him world champion
but when you're the president of the ufc
you have a responsibility
so when you say the judges got it wrong
on that one well now you [ __ ] al
jermaine sterling over
now you [ __ ] them
because he
beat the naysayers he beat the haters
he shut everybody up but not resurfaces
because the most powerful man in the ufc
says he didn't win that fight
which you don't know what you're talking
about
you're wrong dude and you [ __ ] your
fighter over so now he has to go back to
the drawing where he has to deal with
more of this stupid [ __ ] hate
and why
because he won three out of five
but you watch it from cage side on the
little monitor for i mean how do we not
have updated monitors but that's besides
the point
and you and you
rush to judgment for watching it for a
second or third time
which it should be your [ __ ] response
your duty should be to make sure if
you're going to say that stuff
that you're going based off the criteria
that the fighters have to go off of when
it comes to judging but you don't you
came to a quick judgment
and it [ __ ] your fight it [ __ ] your
champion because now that that's out
there and we and and now the media and
the sheep run with it and the mma
experts who work for the ufc and espn
are going to run with it and now you
[ __ ] up the stock of al jermain sterling
and you're wrong dude and anybody else
who says different you're [ __ ] wrong
this is very clear
very clear go back and watch it
now i'll say this go back and watch it
based off how the judges judge a fight
and if your only explanation to given
peter yan that first round is octagon
control
well that's the least
important thing when it comes to judging
there's other things that have to happen
first and al's remain one knows so that
would give him the first round the
second round and the third round clear
as [ __ ] day
so the hate and now jermaine has to stop
somebody has to say it i don't even [ __ ]
how you feel about him personally don't
give a [ __ ] it's very black and white he
was a better fighter that night when
three out of five rounds makes him hands
down undisputed world champion moving on
so then you have al jermaine versus tj
dillashaw that's the fight i don't want
to see peter on al germain anymore i'm
all set
if you want to if you want to give peter
yan some of these other fights and have
him work his way back
cool do that but he's oh for two i'm all
set man i'm sick of watching them fight
i'm sick of watching the build ups i'm
sick of watching the countdowns i'm sick
of watching fans cry about al jermain
i'm sick of people hating al germain i'm
sick of the president of the ufc
shunning his fighter
based off a criteria that nobody has
[ __ ] any control over and he still
won that first round and actually deal
with it even more it's insane so your
new al jermaine versus tj next peter on
has some work to do get back i don't
want to hear a [ __ ] peep about alger
main
uh yawn [ __ ] three i'm all set man
right now i'm all set all right and then
the main event you have the alexander
volkanovsky versus korean zombie
it's mismatched though you know it's a
mismatch you had [ __ ] hot tub time
machine korean zombie sorry chin i'm on
one right now you had hot tub time
machine crane zombie
his skill set it's just even though he's
number four ranked guy in the world
if there's just such a gap there's think
how long korean zombie's been fighting
think how long it's [ __ ] tough to
keep up with these new age fighters men
they're good at everything
alexander volknovsky even said it
himself in the uh post fight press
conference goes i actually pulled back
man because he has kids i don't want his
kids to see this that's what a great guy
he is
but how [ __ ] good is alexander
volkowski my
[ __ ] word he is good there's really
only one fight left for him and it's
just for his own legacy and it's max
holloway so they're gonna do that he
obviously came out there not a mark on
his face korean zombie will never fight
for a title again this was his one shot
to end up working out for him it's all
good he's still a monster still a fan
favorite he goes back to the drawing
board but for volkanovsky the only fight
left at featherweight you know is uh max
holloway we got to see that fight and
hopefully soon because max is healthy
pokinovsky's healthy so might as well do
it
and then you know you got yaya rodriguez
out there which would be fun for
volkanovsky but there's not a ton left
for him in featherweight um
the only fight that would make any sense
for the ufc do would be to pay henry
cejudo to come in there and fight and
challenge alexander volkonovsky at
featherweight which i would love to see
because you're out of your goddamn mind
if you don't think henry cejudo is going
to take him down when it comes to stand
up it's going to get interesting this is
a tweet from henry sudo he says no
cringe straight uh just straight talk
i've entered the u.s uh usada pool i
know i could beat uh vulkanovsky i want
to become the first three division
champion ufc history or or he could shut
up the cringe
it would be a treat for the fans i agree
and what's he saying here can we play it
let's see
i know if i can fight alexander volkanov
i know that i could still beat him like
you know what i mean like it's not about
me killing him it's just about me
beating him yeah yeah he's not winning
by decision
i do have the ability
the speed the wrestling the iq the
experience yeah great toughness the grid
the great really challenging man like
that agree 100 percent it's up to you
phasma it's up to dana white man like
i'm it's not up to the fans i know about
it i've said it i've said it before like
let's let's let's me and alexander can
make a payday off for this you know i
could be from the i could become the
first triple check or he could shut up
the cringe
i mean it'll be a treat for everybody i
know everybody will tell you to watch so
what's up dana
yeah it's like what's up dana so it's
not up to the fans we obviously want it
it's up to dana paying henry cejuda is
worth and that's all this is about
because i think dan would do it but at
the current contract that if they've
agreed to and henry cerdo wants more so
hopefully henry and the ufc can come to
agreement
it's tough if you're dating like yeah
we're looking at pretty black and white
we're looking at the numbers they're not
there man as far as you being this huge
draw so you know for volkanovsky
i doubt they do the henry pseudo fight
next um i i think the only way that this
would happen is
alexander volkowski fights max holloway
beats him stops him very clear there's
no kind of
you know murky waters there like the
other two fights and then
there's not much left for him to do
unless a yaya rodriguez or someone comes
like that out of the woodworks and
you know can challenge him to a good
fight so then you know he's like all
right what do we do with them do we want
to fight henderson that's a big fight
great great fight
do you want to does does volkodovsky
want to go to 55 does he want to go to
lightweight which i think he's small for
a lightweight
i give brian a lot of [ __ ] about him
talking about uh on the fight campaign
fighting uh michael chandler's because
chandler's such a big dude um so i think
for volkanovsky there's definitely
some ways he could go you know
um he's a complete [ __ ] monster he
has to be in your top
two pound-for-pound i think he goes
camaro right now and then volkanovsky
that'd be my i don't i don't know how
the ufc has the rankings for a pound for
pound but
uh volkanovsky's right there and then
obviously camaro is your your pound for
pound guy oh he's number three you got
izzy there too all right that makes
sense
that makes sense you have max always at
six
period at nine not anymore
yeah that makes sense um yeah so here's
some options i guarantee max holloway
fights next if you start just him
there's not a whole lot for him at
featherweight so you could uh pay henry
cejudo which i'd be all for and if
you're not gonna do that there's just
not much form there for him to get up
and then he you could potentially do a
super fight at 55 depending who it is
size wise those 55's are [ __ ] big man
they're really really big you have speed
speed advantage
but i think it does a little dicey for
him at 55 i
truly believe that
um but the card was great man what's
interesting whenever you have four out
of the five fights in the main card go
decision usually like jesus christ dude
this was a snooze fest this was
fantastic
i mean mackenzie dern teacher torres the
tiny tornado was great i'm glad
mackenzie turner got the win you guys
know i'm a huge fan of mackenzie dern
she jumped guard and had the camera
which was [ __ ] filthy
um you know but it was it was a good
night of fights man really really good
night of fights i had so much fun i had
so much [ __ ] fun doing the calves
fight companion so
shout out to everyone who competed on
ufc 273 almost at 274 on ufc 273. it's a
great card great card man and there's a
lot to
you know to dive into what's next for
you know those winners and hamzad
sterling and volkanovsky man so we'll
see what happens it's a good time to be
a ufc fan oh yeah good time what do you
got jen uh real quickly on that though
so now that we saw alexander's
performance how he's like come
incredible right now do you think max
has much of a chance against him now
um
yeah because think think about mac's
last outing
best he's ever looked so now i mean i
don't know who you know
i love alexander volkonovsky i don't
know him personally i know max max is a
buddy but
think how [ __ ] i mean max had won the
best performances ever last time he was
on [ __ ] fire so you bring that same
max
against this alexander volkonovsky yeah
we're going sizzler you're both getting
a gold [ __ ] jacket going to ufc hall
of fame that terrible looking jacket but
you're getting that [ __ ] you know
happy gilmore gold jacket
and [ __ ] you're this the instant
classic man yeah that's the only fight
to make for volkanovsky for his
you know legacy he has to get a dominant
decisive win over max holloway
and i also think you'd win him a ton
more fans because right now i don't know
how you can't be a fan of volcanos he's
such a good person phenomenal fighter
but
you know no one's more loved than max
holloway i don't know anybody don't like
me he's holloway how can he not yeah
great dad great person phenomenal
fighter been doing for a hot second
you know former world champion
uh you know went up to 55 to fight
[ __ ] poirier he's a [ __ ] gangster
man hawaiian gangster so he's so loved i
think a lot of the volkanovsky i don't
say hate whatever you want to call it
criticism comes because it's not a clear
win and
max is so loved a lot of people need to
see that door shut before they jump on
the volkanovsky train and he needs to do
it just for his legacy yeah
what else you got alrighty
so there was we couldn't hear this
because we were on fight companion but
so the translator apparently didn't
capture something that was really
important that korean zombies said so
korean zombie essentially a lot of fans
wrote in a lot of korean fans i'm sure
uh uh zombies trends are left at him
saying i know i can't be ufc champion
which i think is merciful i now know i
can't be champion yeah after that he's
like yeah i know it yeah just you're
talking
light years different skills that was
just it's just it's tough to see man
yeah i wish i wish this corner was
stopped it earlier shout out to herb
dean yeah did a phenomenal job stopping
that fight phenomenal job i would have
stopped it earlier from his corner
especially a dad of three you have all
this legacy in the ufc and wec
we don't have to prove anything it's
just we're not there man you're not
winning this fight i know you are not
winning this fight
we got us there's no point you're
getting paid the same regardless let's
get the [ __ ] out of here get you back on
a flight to south korea get with those
kiddos man yeah his wife was in there
crying and [ __ ] i hate saying it was
tough i didn't like the stoppage at
first for whatever emotional reasons i
think but then looking back i'm like oh
god
and when volkovsky is yeah i was taking
it light
i know what a badass
uh so this is the first ufc and it's
going to continue on from now on uh that
they paid
i guess three different fighters based
on fans choice
the bitcoin
so the first place that
i'll show you real quick the first place
fighter will earn thirty thousand second
place twenty thousand third ten thousand
and here were the winners
um zod wilkanowski yawn yeah
so the fans vote who gets the and so
this on top of their win bonus yeah this
is purely separate but it's all bitcoin
that's cool yeah so it's pretty cool
that they do yeah they get more money
what's insurance about this it's going
to be like the nba all-star vote do you
remember when yao ming was playing
phenomenal player phenomenal but because
the chinese could vote
he would win the number one vote over
lebron or by like
90 million vote you're like jesus christ
like chinese right for their own
so for this like glenn the fans decides
a little dicey because it's basically
who's the most popular gonna win
so like [ __ ] sugar shot o'malley's
gonna win 30 000 every night every time
he fights he's a fan favorite you know
yeah but it's extra money regardless so
no i'm glad they're getting paid yeah
you should i think to be up for it you
have to win though because
sterling should have been the third guy
to win that ten thousand dollars
he won the fight fan vote
yeah that makes sense
uh this is
olynyk's opponent asking him how he beat
him and then olynyk actually showing him
how he did it
[Music]
and uh
yeah the scarf and did he get it
standing
or he got on the ground right he's
showing him statement let me see
[Music]
he's driving his knuckles into his
[ __ ] neck
[Music]
just keeps getting it done doesn't he
yeah old dude super cool dude the oldest
dude just doing the goddamn thing he
looks like the same joke
all the time
uh i think he touched on this look so
hamzat
i guess he met gilbert's kids beforehand
and it kind of messed them up a little
bit i bet yeah it's ashore
look at his face
people think i don't respect the guys
this is the game like i try to play with
his mind and
make let him make some mistakes you know
i love the [ __ ] you know i've been
watching all the time all
that you see [ __ ] you know i tried to
learn something from god his beard is
fantastic
i could not expect all my opponents you
know everyone do it for his family and i
sit before the fight actually it was a
little bit hard to fight him because i
see his kids you know
they come to me ah you fight my daddy
you know i said [ __ ] [ __ ] i don't need
to i say [ __ ] [ __ ] i wanna fight with
some daddy yeah need some killer like me
you know kill somebody
and don't care about [ __ ]
i
go to him i said i respect brother and
you do is you know sorry for
punches and
we do that for our family and
to have fun as well yeah
yeah respect i cannot like the guy i
know dude yep
here's a good heart
uh this is really cool too dana white
said that gilbert burns will get a win
jump win and show money regardless it's
one of the best fights ever yeah i agree
for gilbert burns to pull that off was
not those not those
all right uh one more thing about the
money stuff so this this undercard
fighter michael malott i guess his coach
has a 15 year old daughter that just got
cancer what yeah so he and this is his
debut fight too so he wanted to donate i
guess half of his purse to it but then
dana white says i'll take care of it for
you
so it's like 10 grand or something like
that
let me see
who made his ufc debut today and he had
a ferocious knockout against mickey gall
oh that was a great good post fight
interview where he put his
he put a gofundme over for his boxing
coach who's 15 year old daughter damn it
now you gotta donate to that girlfriend
half of his fight purse
to support him and and her in this
battle against cancer what did you think
of mike's performance and and just what
he had to say after that yeah no he
looked good yeah no the kid looked good
he's flatline he's fun he's fun to watch
mickey and uh
he can keep his 10 grand and i'll do his
show and his win and i'll donate it to
his coaches so how much is that
probably 10 and 10 or 12 and 12. see he
said i'll donate his show and win
showing one so his
his purse was 10 grand i guess so i
don't know a brand new fighter yeah uh
where's that kid out of
he's a canadian guy but he fights out of
team alpha male 1
there's so many things to talk about
from last night it was incredible night
for me the first thing i wanted to
address with the generosity of people
willing to donate to help joey
underscore rodriguez 916. his daughter
angie and his family first you have
after announcing i'd be donating my show
money from last night's fight dana white
said he'd make the donation instead to
keep uh my money i'll still make a
donation but a huge thank you to dana
yep certainly the fans uh
who handed me money from their pockets
of hesitation on what the kgs for blew
me away
thoroughly to the almost 900 silicon
fans who donated to angie's fight to
make a massive difference
fourthly jake paul matching ten thousand
donation with foundation boxing bullies
wow
and how much do they do they hit how
much they need
let's see
oh way over i need to raise 50 000.
this poor [ __ ] kid man
[ __ ] cancer
yeah but um yeah so that was really cool
for dan what to do and
and also the fans just like as he's
walking you know to the locker room
they're just handing him money yeah i'll
donate that's awesome that's [ __ ]
terrible
yeah let me see what kind of cancer his
daughter has okay
joey and louise received
forever changed their lives when they
found out their fifteen-year-old diaries
was diagnosed with stage three lymphoma
this news comes as complete shocked has
been uh healthy has not shown symptoms
and just really undergone a few
procedures we'll start aggressive
treatment in the coming days she's a
sweet bright young girl
angie's father is head backing coach at
team alpha male
jesus christ i know dude it's so sad she
does have a long row to help ahead of
her
that's terrible man at the very least
the way past this goal so that's good
yeah thank god
um so remember we watched this how about
jake paul though i don't know how you
guys can keep hanging i know good man
my show at the improv the other night i
saw that was awesome i said about the i
went to improv again last night he asked
me uh to get him in so i takes rita the
manager there
and uh you know i talked to him back
then
you know the thing about jake paul
obviously the youtube stuff i get all
the hate from the youtube stuff whatever
but as far as a fighter goes you know
you're talking about a guy
who
is chomping at the bit to change the
game
as far as fighter pay goes because he
goes uh do you think i actually have a
shot to get the conor mcgregor fight i
go i think you do i think it happens no
matter what if dana wants to play ball
or not i think it happens
and i said my advice for you is if you
want it to happen in the ufc and have
dana be part of this you gotta back off
the fighter pay
now this is a discussion just between
hopefully you don't mind me talking
about this this is a discussion just
between me and him in the green room at
the improv i go from what i know man
in my experience in the ufc
dana's down to play ball right they had
cm punk they you know they've taken some
risk and you're such a big name but you
also have professional fights so it'd
make a lot of sense for them to
let you fight conor mcgregor in the ufc
but you gotta back off the fighter pay
and i said because
you know
if you if they were to change the
minimum requirement of fighter pay
you know this isn't a thing that would
last a year if they change that there's
no going back you open up pandora's box
so that's costing dana white hundreds of
millions of dollars over you know
whatever how long he's going to be in
the ufc
to make that change
so the juice isn't worth the squeeze for
him anymore let's say
let's say which he wouldn't but let's
say he made 80 million dollars off jake
paul versus conor mcgregor they're still
going to be in the negative
because all the years of changing that
fighter pay which is
thousands of fighters
over the years it doesn't make sense for
dana to do it and i go through all this
and he's not talking he's let me talk to
him yeah that makes sense i'm not yeah i
didn't think of it like that yeah yeah
he goes i don't think i can do it though
if they're not gonna race fighters pay
i'm not gonna do it and i went whoa
you're serious about this i thought it
was kind of a gimmick to get people on
board you know because you had so much
hate it's not dude he doesn't i don't
know if i can do it then then i then
i'll wait till conor gets out of his
contract and i'll fight him on my own
holy [ __ ] this is legit
wants to make a difference when it comes
to this fight game he goes i feel like
that's my duty man i'm the one guy who
can do it holy [ __ ] man good for you
how can you not like him of course i
don't get it
all right well
awesome on jake uh we saw this during
the broadcast but we didn't know what
was going on the duho korean super bowl
oh yeah the hall of
exactly remember i was about seven tiger
thick whiskey's deep at this point but
yeah the they're gonna be the 22 2022 uc
hall of fame and it's their fight was in
2016. i thought it was
not that long ago but yeah super super
boy yeah great fun amazing fight yeah
they both get golden jackets
you should have done something different
those golden jackets that's that's like
rings or something cool yeah just
something different man don't [ __ ]
cop the nfl do your own thing man oh
that's still rings or nfl but whatever
yeah
nfl yet a ring in a jacket but they
could do something cool
chain
sure
yeah did you know triple g fought over
the weekend i did not yep he fought over
the weekend and this is like the ending
sequence here he beat the guy in the
ninth round
and they're saying he looked his age huh
i think that was it some guys against a
guy named mirada i love triple g man god
he was hot for like three years hot as
[ __ ] yeah and then you know some would
say he did beat canelo i completely
thought he beat him yeah the first time
yep and then lost the second one uh i
don't think you ever see that trilogy
fight now or canelo's like alan shut up
the haters because canelo absolutely
mopped the floor of them now
you know his you know father time caught
up with him so if you're canelo's camp
you're looking for a fight you're like
i'll fight f um after seeing that i'll
fight his old ass just just shut him up
a ton of money what else you got uh
jake's brother logan he said he'd be
open to fighting paddy pimlet
um
they're saying he's possibly the next
conor mcgregor right
paul said of pimlic during a recent
appearance on mma hour he's super
charismatic he's entertaining as hell
he's on the come up he's young like me
he's got a real loud mouth i just like
the way he can perform i think also in
the offseason come up like 25 pounds no
no try 75 pounds
uh the kid blows up in the off season
i've never seen anything like it it's
like someone put a pump in him and blows
him blows him up so you can get up to
185 and get down to 185 and possibly do
a ufc match
no i i you know patty pillow is not an
85er he's a you know he's a doughboy at
200 pounds where the [ __ ] he is just
because he eats so much
whatever fish and chips
salt [ __ ] crisp and whatever the hell
else he did you know tea with sugar and
milk and then what the [ __ ] he's doing
to bulk up
um
you know it's something to talk about
but you're not getting logan paul versus
patty pembleton
pimlet um also
you know logan and jake do have to be
careful granted it'd be a huge event no
matter if logan or jake fighting ufc 100
percent
the the jake
and connor fight makes sense for a
number of reasons but that's also gonna
be a stand-up war i don't unless conor's
like [ __ ] take this kid down and
twist his [ __ ]
you know ankle off for a leg lock or
something like that dies for a leg
that'd be a quick fight
but jake and logan do have to be careful
because and i know they wrestle in high
school and they're tremendous especially
wrestle in ohio no punk to to
to you know place in ohio amateur high
school wrestling you got to be
[ __ ] badass man i'll give them that
so they have that uh pedigree
but if the you know
patty's gonna
look i mean
he's gonna chuck you out yeah this
wouldn't be that fun for these guys so
yeah be a little careful like let's say
jake was going after like a colby
comington or hamzad or kamar osman that
ain't a i mean they're they're plus 9
000. that makes no sense the only reason
i'll entertain connor versus jake is
because it'll be a stand-up war and jake
is a professional boxer but if you give
him the him or jake a guy with an actual
grappling pedigree at the highest level
that ain't a fun and they know that
that's not a fun night for them at all
i don't give a [ __ ] what you wrestled in
high school doesn't matter yeah
all right uh real quick one our boy
justin wren he announced that he's gonna
be back in bellator in fall oh dope yeah
hell yeah man good for him i love justin
yeah he's the best
he's the nicest guy ever so anderson
still is going to box someone named
bruno machado who's on the floyd card i
don't know if it's on floyd but is this
dubai support yeah or is that the jake
paul because jake paul said the box too
he's on one of the cards in dubai
yeah
did they say that no so he said august
right jake paul and this is from may
14th
okay but bruno machado's mma fighter and
i looked up his record here oh that's on
the floyd card that's what that is
that's the floor card
uh hey i'm just gonna beat the shows
yeah
i guess he has like five in a row though
that he won sure yeah yeah
by anderson silva yeah
um anderson silva beat [ __ ] julio
chavez jr
beat the [ __ ] out of him i know and he
looks really good natsos yeah
okay this is uh your boy luke rockhold
he's saying he wants to get a title run
to get to izzy but he also has been
calling out paul acosta for a while now
and i guess police does not sign in the
contract
but the ufc offering both contracts
that's what he's uh insinuating uh i'm
annoyed rockhold said on the mma hour
the guy says he wants to make weight he
wants to make 185 he wants the
middleweight fight the ufc wants the
middleweight fight i've i'm [ __ ] all
in my management wants it i want it i'm
ready to go just making excuses and
getting cold feet i don't know exactly
what is going on but i'm just ready to
go i've been training every day all day
nothing stopped me right now let's go
sign the [ __ ] fight why is paulo casa
getting scared of not sending the
[ __ ] contract the contract is there
it's ready for you i'd love that fight
so paul costa on his social media has
been kind of weird but funny kind of
weird and he wrote this most recently as
a
i don't follow social media
so does he do like troll things
i'll show you some of his posts and
you'll see but this he's basically
responding to luke rockhold
so this is uh luke rockhold luke
rockhold said your steroids aren't
working anymore and you [ __ ] got
caught up you're looking for a way out
he's always needed assistance in
whatever ways it's obvious [ __ ] show
up show up show out let's go
and this is what he posted paul acosta
after this [ __ ] luke rockhold said i
will reveal curiosity vitor is my dad
and it happened when him and my young
and sexy mom gets in romance on real
diagrams brazil and everyone knows
that's what that's what when he bring me
to ufc the staff called me baby vitor
it's very odd but then uh he posted this
well first of all look at his banner
there does that islam makashev and
as uh hawkins yeah
hawkins
um and then he did this
i felt something wet and hot in my shoe
and then that's john jones on his feet
but that's him naked
yeah it's so bizarre and then this one
i don't know what the hell this is but
okay is that him as putin
is that it
i don't know okay keep going this is the
one that i thought was funniest
man what the [ __ ] i'm looking for
god have a mess i you so
i'll pray for you he's a handsome devil
that boy is beautiful
so nick actually showed me this post and
i was just like what the hell he's an
interesting dude he's a very weird but
kind of funny dude
i don't know what's going on here he's
just changing in the gym
interesting yeah
and
i doubt vitoris is dead no he's just
saying crazy stuff this is the last one
it's just uh hamza trying to pronounce
ohio i guess he has an issue in ohio
that's my hometown bro ohio
hawaii ohio
hanzo
i mean i struggle with english too man
trust that
ohio
makes you like him even more right yeah
he's still like his personality open up
a ton yeah he's just a laughable guy man
i think that's pretty much it dude we
have fights coming up though
uh you got one great fight on the ufc
fight night this week which is uh for
the 911 title contender vicente luce
muhammad which is a great [ __ ] fight
they fought before yeah so
um you know i'm a vicente luke fan of
the also muhammad finn great [ __ ]
fight that's fine night written all over
it
all over rust card is complete trash and
that's not throwing shade at anybody
fighting on this card but for the ufc
standard you're coasting this one and
you're just coasting you're just trying
to check the box for espn but that main
event is fantastic
great fight the best card of the weekend
is bellator by far on the friday on
friday you have aj mckee versus in the
rematch against pitbull which is a great
fight this can be a huge night for aj
mckee to cement his legacy then you have
that light heavyweight uh world
championship fight nemcob versus corey
anderson
that's an intriguing fight man when we
had cory anderson on a food truck
a while back when i still with showtime
he was talking about how excited he's to
get a hold of nimkov i'm so interested
about what happens in that fight then
you have one of my personal fan
favorites aaron pico
uh is fighting he just resigned with
bellator you have timothy johnson and
um the undercard's
solid as well super solid you have
fortune
uh crutchmere on there rafael on there
solid card man definitely been the ufc's
it's just disrespectful at this point
like all right espn's like what
like sorry you said we have to do 40
fights this one the 40. can't all be
bangers but we gave you a great main
event this man's like makes sense
is that it that's it alright kids thanks
for watching thanks for liking
subscribing let's go ahead and hit that
subscribe button on the thick boy
youtube we're growing man we're just
over 130 000 subs we've been rolling
since january so we're a cooking um but
this thursday friday saturday i'm in
phoenix arizona stand up live we're
almost sold out let's sell these [ __ ]
out i've never sold out stand up live
just a big venue um but phoenix were my
favorite spots i would be at jt's wings
on saturday just getting stuff full of
wings
um
and then austin texas uh breaking news
there well i now sit on my instagram but
breaking news as far as podcast goes
um we we changed venues we're at the cap
city comedy club the new cap city i was
going to open up their club and they
decided to put your boy in the historic
paramount theater where uh andrew
schultz shot his special there rogans
performed there whitney cummings the
who's who has been in the paramount
theater so it's a big night for your boy
let's sell that [ __ ] out to the moon
tower comedy festival one night one show
only with the thick boy crew at the
historic paramount theater in austin
texas so instead of doing friday
saturday i'm just doing saturday one big
ass show at the paramount theater
april 23rd in austin texas for the moon
tower economy festival april 22nd 21st
which thursday and friday i'll be
bouncing around on everybody else's
shows for the economy festival that's
what you do during economy festivals so
i'll be jumping around so uh april 23rd
paramount theater austin texas yup and
then just announced uh charlotte north
carolina charlotte
uh north carolina the comedy zone in
charlotte great uh venue may 5th through
the 7th is charlotte north carolina
comedy zone come get some charlotte
mugsy bogues is open for me
just plain
but bring your larry johnson grandmama
jerseys that'd be cool huh or bring your
wrecked chapman jerseys or bring steph
curry's dad jersey that'd be sweet
um but i'm in charlotte may 5th through
the 7th but this week most importantly
phoenix arizona april 14th through the
16th that's this thursday friday
saturday get your tickets right now
thickboy.com or fatkz.com
and then austin texas one night only
april 23rd at the paramount theater
let's ride
show out for your thick friend here all
right love you guys thanks for watching
thanks for subscribing liking thanks for
doing everything watching the combat
fight campaign thanks everybody who run
the thick mudder 500 strong say what and
we're only growing join the movement
it's a grand old time i'll keep you
posted for the next one might be in
august in chicago keep you guys posted
but that's it love you guys phoenix see
you this weekend
you